[Music]
Parkinson's is the second most common
neurodegenerative disease after
Alzheimer's the most visible features of
this disease are a slowness of movement
muscle rigidity and tremors at rest
there are also many often debilitating
non-motor symptoms some of which may
present before the motor problems
Parkinson's affects many areas of the
nervous system and different types of
neurons however much focus has been
placed on neurons in brain regions
associated with the overt motor symptoms
notably a region of the midbrain called
the substantia [ __ ] pars compacta this
region forms part of a major pathway in
the brain that's critical for
facilitating movements in Parkinson's
dopaminergic neurons in the substantia
[ __ ] gradually died leading to the
malfunction of this pathway and the
characteristic motor problems drugs that
replace or mimic dopamine are often used
to treat these modes of deficits but
they grow less effective over time deep
brain stimulation may also be used to
treat symptoms however no current
treatment slows the neuro degeneration a
distinctive pathology in most cases of
Parkinson's is clumps of misfolded
proteins within neurons Lewy bodies are
the most common type
a characteristic components of these is
a misfolded protein called alpha
synuclein these molecules can form small
repeated units called oligomers or
longer fibrous mounting evidence
indicates that these are toxic to
neurons and play a key role in driving
parkinson's unwanted proteins are
normally cleared by the cells different
types of protein degrading machinery
some evidence points to these systems
being overwhelmed by misfolded alpha
synuclein and this might be a key factor
in what kills the neurons parkinson's
has also been linked to problems with
mitochondria mitochondria provides cells
with the energy to perform vital
functions their highly dynamic and
confused together or break up into
smaller versions in response to a cell's
energy demands they can also be
transported to areas of a cell that need
them the most
however in Parkinson's these processes
can be impaired and mitochondria are
unable to sustain proper neuronal
function
as they become old or damaged
mitochondria are removed and replaced
again this recycling is thought to be
disrupted in Parkinson's leading to the
accumulation of damaged or worn out
mitochondria another idea is that the
cells called glia surrounding neurons
may play a role in Parkinson's as
dopamine neurons are lost one particular
type of grille cell called microgram is
thought to take up the resulting
cellular debris triggering an immune
response once activated they release
inflammatory cytokines which activate
neighboring microglia and another type
of glial cell called astrocytes
chemicals released by activated micro
clear and astrocytes have been shown to
in general it remains unclear which
mechanisms drive the disease process in
Parkinson's what is clear is that with
time more areas of the nervous system
developed pathology and one emerging
idea is that this happens through the
transmission of misfolded alpha
synuclein while a multifactorial nature
of Parkinson's disease progression might
make it hard to fully understand it does
provide a number of potential
therapeutic targets for slowing or even
halting the neuro degeneration
for example enhancing the clearance of
abnormal proteins and blocking their
transmission improving the function of
mitochondria and targeting the neuro
inflammation are all currently active
areas of research
[Music]
you
you